Je ne suis pas même « voluptueuse », pour employer un mot plus sophistiqué.
Ne nous voilons pas la face.
Je suis la GROSSE, en majuscules.
Je suis l'éléphant dans la pièce.
Quand je suis montée ici,
certains d'entre vous ont pensé :
« Ah, ça va être comique,
puisque tout le monde sait que les gros sont drôles. »
(Rires)
Ou sinon vous pensiez : « D’où tient-elle sa confiance en elle ? »
Parce qu'une grosse qui est confiante est presque inimaginable.
Ceux qui apprécient la mode
ont peut-être remarqué combien je suis belle
dans cette robe par Beth Ditto --
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup.
Certains d'entre vous ont pensé :
« Hmm, le noir aurait donné un effet amincissant. »
(Rires)
Vous vous êtes demandé, explicitement ou non,
si je suis diabétique, ou si j'ai un partenaire,
ou si je mange des glucides après 19h.
(Rires)
Vous vous êtes peut-être inquiétés car vous avez mangé des glucides après 19h
hier soir, et que vous devriez renouveler l'abonnement au club de sport.
Ces jugements sont sournois.
Ils peuvent être dirigés contre des individus
ou des groupes, ou contre nous-mêmes.
Cette façon de penser s'appelle la grossophobie.
Comme toutes les oppressions systématiques,
la grossophobie est ancrée dans des constructions complexes
telles que le capitalisme, la patriarchie, le racisme.
Cela la rend vraiment difficile à voir,
sans parler de la combattre.
Notre culture assimile
la surcharge pondérale avec le mal :
le gros est paresseux, glouton, malsain, irresponsable,
et moralement suspect.
Et nous tendons à voir la minceur
comme une bonne qualité :
la personne mince est responsable,
a du succès, contrôle son appétit, son corps, sa vie.
Nous voyons ces idées souvent répétées
dans les médias, dans la politique de santé publique,
chez le médecin,
dans les conversations de tous les jours,
et dans nos propres attitudes.
Nous pouvons même blâmer les obèses
pour la discrimination rencontrée
car, après tout, si nous n'aimons pas ça, il ne suffit que de perdre du poids.
Facile.
Ce biais grossophobe est devenu tellement ancré
dans notre façon d'estimer nous-mêmes et les autres
que nous ne nous demandons pas pourquoi autant de dédain pour les gens
d'une certaine taille, ni d'où vient ce dédain.
Mais nous devons le remettre en question
puisque la valeur que nous attachons à l'apparence
touche chacun d'entre nous.
Voulons-nous vivre dans une société
où les gens sont privés de leurs droits en tant qu'humains
s'ils ne rentrent pas dans une catégorie arbitraire de taille acceptée ?
Alors, quand j'avais 6 ans,
ma sœur enseignait le ballet à des petites filles dans notre garage.
J'avais 30 cm de plus en hauteur et en largeur que les autres.
Au moment de donner notre premier spectacle,
j'étais très excitée de porter un joli tutu rose.
J'allais briller.
Alors que les autres fillettes se glissaient aisément dans leur costume,
aucun tutu n'était assez grand pour moi.
Comme j'étais déterminée à ne pas être exclue du spectacle,
je me suis tournée vers ma mère
et assez fort que tout le monde puisse m'entendre
j'ai dit : « Maman, je n'ai pas besoin d'un tutu.
J'ai besoin d'un double. »
(Rires)
Merci, maman.
(Applaudissements)
Et quoique je ne m'en rendais pas compte à l'époque,
réclamer de la place dans un merveilleux double tutu
a été mon premier pas vers un activisme radical pour les gros.
Alors, je ne dis pas que tout ce truc d'amour de soi
a été une promenade du dimanche sur un chemin d'acceptation de mon corps
depuis ce jour en classe.
Loin de là.
J'ai rapidement appris que vivre en dehors de ce que la majorité décide est normal
peut être frustrant et isolant.
Cela fait 20 ans que je déballe et déconstruis ces messages de la société
et ça a été des montagnes russes.
On m'a ri au nez, des gens en voiture m'ont insultée en passant,
et on m'a dit que je délirais.
J'ai aussi des sourires des étrangers
qui reconnaissent ce qu'il faut pour se promener dans la rue
la démarche fière et la tête haute.
(Hourra)
Merci.
Et tout ce temps, la petite fille de six ans que j’étais est restée avec moi,
et elle m'a aidée à me mettre devant vous aujourd'hui,
une grosse sans excuse, sans complexe,
une personne qui se refuse d'admettre
que d'autres doivent me dire
comment je navigue dans ce monde avec mon corps à moi.
(Applaudissements)
Et je ne suis pas seule.
Je fais partie d'une communauté internationale de personnes
qui choisissent, plutôt que de juste
accepter passivement que nos corps sont gros et probablement le resteront,
de nous épanouir dans ces corps tels qu'ils sont aujourd'hui.
Les gens qui honorent nos forces et qui travaillent avec, pas contre,
nos limitations perçues,
des gens qui valorisent la santé
comme étant un état entier bien plus
qu'un chiffre sur un tableau d'Indice de Masse Corporelle désuet.
À la place, nous valorisons la santé mentale, la valorisation de soi,
et le bien-vivre comme étant des aspects vitaux de notre bien-être global.
Ces gens ne croient pas que vivre dans nos corps de gros
nous empêche de faire quoique ce soit, en fait.
Il y a des médecins, des universitaires, des blogueurs,
qui ont écrit des volumes entiers
sur les aspects multiples de ce sujet complexe.
Il y a des fashionistas qui revendiquent la beauté de leur corps
en portant des « groskinis » et des crop tops,
en montrant la chair qu'on nous a tous appris à cacher.
Il y a des athlètes gros
qui courent des marathons, qui font du yoga ou du kick-boxing,
toujours en narguant avec le doigt d'honneur le statu quo.
Et ces gens m'ont appris que cette politique radicale du corps
est l'antidote à une culture qui nous donne honte de notre corps.
Pour être claire, je ne dis pas que les gens ne peuvent pas modifier leur corps
si c'est ce qu'ils veulent faire.
Se revendiquer peut être l'une des meilleures affirmations de soi qui soit
et peut ressembler à plein de choses :
de la coiffure à des tatouages, au remodelage du corps,
aux hormones, à la chirurgie et, oui, à la perte de poids.
C'est très simple. C'est votre corps,
et c'est vous qui décidez ce que vous en faites.
Mon moyen de m'engager,
c'est de faire toutes les choses que nous les gros ne sont pas
censés faire - il y en a beaucoup,
j'invite d'autres à venir me rejoindre et nous créons de l'art ensemble.
Le fil conducteur de la majorité du travail
est la réclamation des espaces qui ne sont pas faits pour les grands corps :
des podiums de mode à des spectacles en club,
des piscines municipales aux salles de spectacle les plus connues.
Et reprendre ces espaces en masse n'est pas seulement un choix artistique
mais aussi un moyen radical de créer une communauté.
C’était tellement vrai d'AQUAPORKO ! --
(Rires)
l’équipe de natation synchronisée fémigrosse
que j'avais commencée avec un groupe d'amies à Sydney.
L'impact de voir des grosses rebelles
dans des bonnets fleuris et maillots
qui projetaient insouciamment leurs jambes en l'air
ne devrait pas être sous-estimé.
(Rires)
Au cours de ma carrière, j'ai appris que la corpulence est politique en soi
et que les corps qui ne s'en excusent pas
laissent pantois.
Quand Kate Champion, directrice
de la célèbre compagnie de danse, Force Majeure,
m'a demandée de devenir son associée artistique
sur une œuvre réservée aux danseurs corpulents,
j'ai littéralement sauté sur l'occasion.
Littéralement.
« Rien à perdre » est une œuvre faite en collaboration avec des personnes
de grande taille qui ont puisé dans leur vécu
afin de créer une œuvre aussi variée et authentique que nous tous.
Et c’était aussi loin du ballet que vous puissiez imaginer.
L’idée même d'une œuvre de danse pour des gros, venant d'une compagnie
prestigieuse a été pour le moins controversé
puisque rien de tel n'a jamais été vu sur des planches jusqu'alors,
nulle part au monde.
Les gens ont été sceptiques.
« Que voulez-vous dire par ' danseurs corpulents ' ?
Corpulent style, taille 40-42 ?
Où ont-ils appris à danser ?
Vont-ils pouvoir tenir jusqu'à la fin d'une production entière ? »
Mais malgré le scepticisme,
« Rien à perdre » s'est produit à guichets fermés pendant le Festival de Sydney.
Nous avons reçu des critiques élogieuses,
fait une tournée, gagné des prix, et avons été médiatisés dans 27 langues.
Ces images incroyables de notre troupe ont fait le tour du monde.
Je ne me rappelle même plus combien de fois des gens de toutes les tailles
m'ont dit que le spectacle avait changé leur vie,
combien il les avait aidés à recalibrer
leur rapport à leur corps et à celui d'autrui,
et combien il les avait obligés à confronter leurs biais.
Mais, bien sûr, le travail qui met les autres au défi
ne va pas sans détracteurs.
On m'a dit que je glorifiais l’obésité.
On m'a menacée de mort
pour avoir osé créer des œuvres centrées sur les corps et les vies
des gros et qui nous valorisent.
On m'a même traitée de la
« Daesh de l'épidémie de l’obésité » --
(Rires)
un commentaire tellement absurde qu'on en rigole.
Mais cela trahit aussi la panique,
la terreur,
que la grossophobie peut évoquer.
C'est cette crainte qui nourrit l'industrie des régimes alimentaires.
Ce qui empêche tellement d'entre nous d’être à l'aise avec nos propres corps,
en voulant être la photo « après »
du tandem « avant-après » - avant de commencer à vivre.
Parce que le vrai éléphant dans la salle, c'est la grossophobie.
L'activisme n'admet pas cette crainte.
En militant pour le respect pour tous,
nous pourrons bouger l'inertie sociétale afin d'accepter toutes les formes
et commencer à célébrer les nombreux moyens d'avoir un corps.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)